hey everyone is cereth red sterner sorry
and calm and in this video we're going
to go over canes crutches and walkers
and as always whenever you get done
watching this video over assistive
devices you can access the free quiz for
exams in nursing school you want to make
sure that you are familiar with
assistive devices such as crutches canes
and walkers and in our next videos we
will be talking about canes and walkers
so with crutches what you specifically
want to know for exams is how they
should properly fit the different types
of gates you can do with crutches how a
patient should go up and down the stairs
with crutches and how they should get up
or set down in a chair so first let's
talk about proper fit what are some
things that you need to see in your
patient that tells you that those
crutches fit them properly well before a
patient even starts using crutches the
crutches will have to be adjusted based
on the patient's height and they can be
adjusted at the bottom and at the talk
and usually on most crutches there's a
height range where you will slide the
part of the crutch to meet whatever your
patient's hype is also there's a hand
grip on the crutch that can be adjusted
as well so some things you want to
remember is that you want to be looking
at the gap between the crutch rest pad
and axilla the armpit there should be a
gap there it should be about two to
three fingers width which ends up being
about one to one and a half inches and
the reason you want this gap is because
while the patient is using using the
crutch they need to be putting all their
weight on the hand grips rather than on
this crutch rest pad via that Scylla
area because in this area you have
nerves and if they're putting all their
weight on that number one it's really
going to be uncomfortable and hurt but
it's also gonna damage those nerves in
that area also you want to be looking at
the hand grips and where they're lining
up on the body the hand grips should be
even with the top of the hip line so
whenever the patient actually uses
the handgrips their elbow will be
slightly bent at about 30 degrees now
let's talk about the different types of
gates while using crutches and you want
to make sure that you really truly
understand these different types of
gates that I'm going to go over because
exams love to give you a description of
a gate that a patient may be doing while
using crutches and you'll have to
identify it so before a patient even
starts ambulating with crutches at first
you want to make sure that they are
wearing a gait belt for safety also
before they start doing one of these
type of gates they're going to start in
the tripod position and it looks
something like this and it forms like a
triangle Hintz looks like a tripod and
this is where the crutches are about 6
inches out diagonally from the feet so
first let's start out with the point
gates we have three of them we have the
2-point gate the 3-point gate and the
four-point gate now how you can keep
these straight is that you need to ask
yourself how many points are on the
ground hence how many crutches are on
the ground and how many feet are on the
ground whenever you're looking at the
scenario because each crutch counts as a
point and each foot counts as a point so
the two point we're gonna have two
points on the ground at a time whether
it's a crutch or a foot so what does it
look like well this is where the patient
will move the crutch on the injured side
so we're going to say it's the right
side so they move the right crutch and
they move the left foot together then
they will move the left crutch on that
non injured side and the right foot
together so you have two points
next is the 4-point gate and it's a
little bit similar to the two-point gate
but each point is moving separately
because remember in two point they were
moving together the Rye and the left
moving together and then the left and
the right moving together be here with
four point they're separate so the
patient will move the right crutch
witches will say the injured side then
they'll move the left foot then they'll
move the left crutch and then they'll
move the right foot
and the last point gay is the 3.8 and
this is where they move both crutches
and the injured leg together at the same
time and then they will move the non
injured leg
and then lastly we have the two swing
gates and it's either a swing to gate or
a swing through gate and let the names
help you so the swing to gate is where
the patient will move both crutches
forward then they will hint swing or
move both legs forward and place them at
the placement of where the crutches are
located
now the swing through is very similar to
this they will move both crutches
forward then they will move both legs
forward can't swing both legs forward
but they will swing it pass the crutch
placement
now let's talk about stairs how does a
patient navigate up and down the stairs
while using crutches well you want to
keep these two straight and what I'm
meaning is which leg is going to go
first up the step versus which leg is
going to go down the step first and to
remember that remember good up and bad
down so whatever a patient is going up
the stairs their good leg is going to go
first up on the step followed by the
crutches and the bad leg which will
proceed and go up the step
now whenever they're going down the
steps they're going to move the crutches
down onto the stab that will help
provide stability followed by the Bab
leg because a bad leg is going to go
down and then they're going to move the
good leg down on to the step
and lastly we're going to wrap up the
lecture and talk about how a patient
sits down and gets up while using
crutches
to sit in the chair the patient's going
to back up to the chair and fill the
chair with the non injured leg and when
the patient fills the chair with a non
injured leg they're gonna stop and move
both crutches over to the injured side
for support then the patient's going to
grip the hand grips and slightly bend
the non injured leg and feel behind them
and then set in the chair while keeping
the injured leg extended to get up from
the chair the patient is going to take
the crutches and put them on the injured
side for support he's going to keep the
injured leg extended and push up on the
non injured side and using the hand
grips of the crutches then he's going to
put the crutches in position okay you
want to make sure that you're familiar
with how a cane should properly fit a
patient how to actually walk with a cane
how a patient should go up and down
stairs with a cane and how they should
get up from a chair or sit down in a
chair with the cane therefore let's
start with the proper fit how do you
know as the nurse of this cane actually
fits your patient well before a patient
uses a cane for the first time it has to
be adjusted most canes can be adjusted
at the bottom by sliding the cane into
location of where it should go to fit
the patient but once the patient is
holding the cane or once they have the
cane standing beside their body how do
you know it actually fits the patient
well there's two ways you can tell the
first way is that the top of the cane
which is felt this area here should be
even with the great trochanter the great
trochanter is a prominence of the femur
so that's all but the cane should rest
about right there
whenever the patient's standing up and
has the cane beside of them or the top
of the cane should be even with the
wrist crease that is closest to the hand
so those are two ways you can tell also
whenever the patient is
clean the cane the elbows should be
flexed at a 15 to 30 degree angle so
those are some things that you can look
for as the nurse to tell you that this
cane properly fits your patient now
let's talk about how a patient should
walk with the cane before a patient
starts using their cane and practicing
with it you want to make sure that they
are wearing a gait belt for safety in
addition you're going to stand on the
patient's weak side in case they lose
their balance so whenever they start
using the cane they want to make sure
that they're in the proper position the
position that they want to be in they
want to make sure that they are
positioning the tip of the cane at least
four inches from the side of the foot
and they want to hold the cane on the
strong side of the body so remember that
the cane needs to be on the strong side
very important concept to remember so
how are they going to actually ambulate
with this cane well to emulate with a
cane what they're going to do is they're
going to move the cane with the weak
side together forward so they move the
cane along with the weak side together
and then they will move the strong side
forward
so how does a patient go up and down the
stairs with a cane well the concept is
the same like how we learned with
crutches remember I told you to remember
up equals good down equals bad and what
we're referring to is the good leg going
up first which would be the strong leg
versus whenever we're going down the
stairs it would be the bad leg that's
gonna go first so the weak side
therefore how do we go up the stairs
using that concept well what the patient
wants to do is they want to hold the
cane on that good / strong side then
they're going to move the good leg up
onto the step and they're gonna put
weight onto the cane and then move the
cane and the bad leg up onto the step
now to go down the stairs the patient
again is going to hold the cane on the
good side that strong side they're gonna
move the cane down onto the step with
the bad leg so the bad leg is going down
then they're going to move the good leg
down onto the step and lastly let's talk
about how a patient will sit down and
get up
using a cane to sit down with a cane the
patient is going to back up to the chair
until he fills the chair with the back
of the legs then the patient will allow
the cane to rest on the side of the
chair and place both hands on the chairs
armrest
and place weight on the hands while
keeping the weak leg extended out and
been the strong leg to sit down to sit
up with the cane a patient's going to
place the cane on the strong side and
lean forward in the chair while keeping
the weak leg slightly extended forward
then the patient is going to push down
on the canes hand grip and the chair
armrest and then put weight on the
strong leg and stand in position with
the cane when you're studying Walker's
for your exams there are some things you
want to remember you want to remember
the proper fit what are those
characteristics that the Walker actually
fits your patient how to walk with the
walker so the gait and how the patient
to get up and sat down in a chair so
first let's talk about proper fit how do
you know that this Walker actually fits
your patient well before a patient even
uses a walker for the first time it has
to be adjusted and on most Walker's
they're adjusted down at the bottom you
have to adjust each leg there's four of
those legs so you've adjusted the Walker
now what do you look for these are
things you want to remember for your
exams well have the patient hold onto
the hand grips while they're standing
with the Walker and you're going to look
at that elbow there should be about a
fifteen to thirty degree bend in the
elbows also when the patient holds their
arms down at their side their wrist
crease should line up with those hand
grips those two things really tell you
that this Walker fits this patient the
next thing you want to know about is the
gait
how does your patient actually walk with
the Walker and this is something that
you really want to pay attention to for
exams so you want to make sure that
you're paying attention to what's moving
first is that the walkers at the weak
side or the strong side and how that
order goes so before a patient actually
uses a walker for those first couple
times you want to make sure that you
have applied a gait belt to their waist
for safety also you want to stand on the
patient's weak side in case they start
to stumble or fall you want to be there
and you want to tell the patient before
they start ambulating with their Walker
that they don't want to stare down at
their feet while they're doing it even
though that just seems like something
natural you want to do that can actually
mess them up and cause them to fall they
want to look straight ahead just like if
they were walking normally and the
starting position how do they start out
walking with their Walker well they want
to make sure that the back tips of the
Walker match up with the middle of their
foot now let's talk about how you
actually ambulate with a walker to
ambulate with the Walker first the
patient's going to get in position and
hold onto the handgrips of the Walker
first they will lift and move the Walker
forward and then make sure all four
points of the Walker are touching the
ground then they will move the weeks
put weight on the hands the other hand
grips and then move the strong side
again they will lift the Walker move it
forward make sure all four points are on
the ground then they will move the weak
side put weight on the handgrips and
then move the strong side
to sit down in a chair a patient is
going to take their Walker hold on to
the hand grips and slowly back up to the
chair until they fill the chair with the
back of their legs then they're going to
slightly extend that weak leg out and
take their hands and position them
behind them and then their strong leg
and feel for the chairs armrest and then
set down to get up from the chair what
the patient's going to do is of course
make sure the Walker is out in front of
them they're going to lean forward out
of the chair make sure their hands are
on the hand rest and slightly extend
that weak leg out then they're going to
put weight on their hands by pushing up
on the armrest of the chair and with
their strong leg and putting their hands
on the hand grip of the Walker then they
are ready to ambulate
and again to do that they will lift the
Walker make sure all points are on the
floor move that weak leg put weight on
the handgrips and then move the strong
side thank you so much for watching
don't forget to take the free quiz and
to subscribe to our channel for more
videos